bonsoir tirer valade merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france michelle bachelet at
elle raison de lancer cet appel selon
vous pour ne pas utiliser cette
technologie pendant les manifestations
la haut commissaire de l'onu a tout à
fait raison je crois qu'aujourd'hui se
pose un problème fondamental presque
deux sociétés dans quel monde voulons
nous vivre
est ce que c'est un monde de
surveillance ou la reconnaissance
faciale permettra à tout un chacun
en tout cas d'être pisté par l'état des
troncs sera exactement où vous êtes à
n'importe quel moment par la
surveillance ou alors on veut le respect
de la liberté fondamentale et notamment
celle de la vie privée c'est une
véritable un véritable tournant de
société dans lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui
la commission européenne a fait un livre
blanc au mois de février qui se prononce
en ce sens de faire une pause dans le
cadre de la reconnaissance faciale
là plusieurs sociétés ont aujourd'hui
ibm amazon et d'autres suspendus comme
vous l'avez rappelé les logiciels de
reconnaissance faciale leur distribution
aux forces de police alors ce n'est
qu'une suspension amazon a bien précisé
que syntec pour une durée d'un an
mais aujourd'hui on est vraiment un
tournant
la vidéo vous l'avez remarqué il ya un
glissement sémantique qui ceux qui se
posent la vidéo protection et
surveillance est devenue la
vidéoprotection pour des raisons
sécuritaires on est en train d'essayer
avec la technologie moderne de
d'utiliser la reconnaissance faciale
comme étant une ac mais pour permettre
de de piste et tout un chacun notamment
au niveau des manifestations dans la
foule donc il faut vraiment réfléchir à
tout cela et la cnil faut bien rappeler
ne serez seul biais encore quelques mois
il faut un véritable débat un véritable
débat société publique dans lequel on
saurait exactement les tenants et
aboutissants entre les pros tout
sécuritaire où les pros liberté et vie
privée
la crainte notamment soulevé serait de
d'accroître encore davantage les
discriminations c'est votre avis c'est
mon avis c'est la réalité
malheureusement qu'il trouve une
nouvelle fois il ya encore deux jours à
detroit aux états unis un afro américain
a été reconnu par une reconnaissance
faciale à tort il s'est fait interpeller
devant son domicile devant ses enfants
cette petite fille de deux ans et en
fait l'ordinateur c'était bien
évidemment tromper on a un pourcentage
en la calculer aujourd'hui plus plus
nettement
si vous êtes une femme noire vous avez
35 % d'erreurs possibles par rapport à
la reconnaissance faciale qui est un
système de probabilités de
reconnaissance à ce n'est pas une
certitude
donc aujourd'hui si vous êtes
afro-américains si vous êtes asiatiques
qui vous êtes une femme vous avez des
chances de discrimination beaucoup plus
importante que si vous êtes un homme
blanc donc aujourd'hui la technologie
même si elle arrive à plus de maturité
est aujourd'hui particulièrement peu
fiables par rapport à une au dessin
qu'on lui qu'on lui laissera savoir la
reconnaissance d'une foule alors il ya
ces réticences par rapport à ces
technologies mais dans les
manifestations on le voit aujourd'hui
tout le monde film est ce que là il n'y
a pas un risque également de que ça
serve de support en tout cas pour pour
les autorités alors il ya le quand vous
filmez dans une manifestation c'est tout
à fait possible dans certaines
conditions il faut pas que les personnes
soit individualisé mais si c'est un
mouvement de foule n'y a pas de souci en
revanche avec la reconnaissance faciale
là on va beaucoup plus loin c'est
beaucoup plus intrusif vous avez une
reconnaissance des personnes qui vont
être participé à la manifestation
et c'est ce qui se passe des genres
aujourd'hui on a ne serait ce que par
des drones par exemple avec des caméras
de reconnaissance faciale avec des
caméras piétons dans sont embarqués sur
des sur les policiers ou des membres de
forces de l'ordre
vous avez déjà alors en france
normalement mais parce que le cas il n'y
a pas de cadre légal pourrait pour cela
mais dans certains pays ça existe déjà
donc vous avez cette possibilité que on
puisse participer une manifestation et
être reconnu par un algorithme de
reconnaissance faciale et ce qui
dissuade certaines personnes aujourd'hui
de participer tout simplement d'exercer
leur droit démocratique de participation
une manifestation donc bien évidemment
tous à nenê n'est pas possible et il
faut absolument réglementer tout ça il
pas nos cadres aujourd'hui il existe
hâtif suffisant donc la cnil en est
d'ailleurs à l'armée elle est
aujourd'hui saisi d'un certain nombre de
réglementations d'expérimentation mais
pas sur un sur quelque chose depuis
large donc aujourd'hui il faut
absolument que le débat public
intervienne et que on est un cadre légal
qui permette de réglementer les
finalités le caractère proportionné de
ces intrusions dans notre vie privée et
la possibilité pour les forces de
l'ordre de pouvoir utiliser ces ses
algorithmes très quoi thierry valette on
voit il ya deuxième une deuxième attaque
au couteau en grande bretagne qui
utilise beaucoup d'ailleurs les caméras
de vidéosurveillance 7 utilise néanmoins
dans des opérations de recherches en
tout cas du terrorisme alors bien
entendu c'est là c'est un problème de
finalité lorsqu'on est à la recherche de
quelqu'un de tout à fait particulier
comme un terroriste potentiel alors ça
pose aussi des problèmes de savoir qui
va être considérée comme terroriste ou
non là dans l'absolu vous côté la
question je vous dirais bien évidemment
oui pour des raisons de sécurité oui
mais ça pose néanmoins des problèmes
surtout que la fiabilité et surtout en
écosse
ça ne marche pas du tout forcément aussi
bien que ça on l'a vu avec des
expérimentations sur des salles de
football où on essayait de le filtrer
les hooligans et ça n'a pas du tout
fonctionné
merci beaucoup thierry valade pour votre
analyse merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rtl france